I'm onboard that Navy ship now the
acting Navy secretary who fired the
captain on board the USS Roosevelt
apparently described him as being too
stupid or naive for the job
he made the comments over the ship's PA
system and Jennifer Griffin has that
story now from the Pentagon what
happened Jennifer well bill the acting
Navy secretary Thomas Mowgli flew out to
Guam without a public affairs team and
delivered a blistering profanity-laced
speech chastising the sailors on board
the USS Roosevelt and mocking captain
Brett Crozier's decision to put in
writing why he thought most of the
sailors on board the aircraft carrier
needed to be removed from the ship in
Guam as the number of kovat cases on
board exploded as muddly spoke over the
ship's intercom system many of the same
sailors who cheered for their captain as
he left the ship after the acting Navy
secretary fired him for ignoring the
chain of command expressed stunned
disbelief when mode Lee described the
captain's actions as a betrayal of them
and the Navy Crozier himself has since
tested positive for codeine
[Applause]
you do your jobs
and that's what I expect you to do and I
guess what I expect every monster on
this ship to do it's a 2-year jobs mode
Lee issued a statement moments ago
explaining why he used profanity
suggesting that is how sailors talk 173
sailors on board the ship have tested
positive nearly 2,000 have been removed
from the ship many wonder whether the
Acting Secretary will also fire the Navy
leaders who took the decision to make a
five-day port call in to Vietnam in
March that decision was not made by
captain Crozier I'm told bill Thank You
Jennifer Jennifer Griffin the Pentagon
on that story